hi and welcome to serverless migration
station I'm Wesley from Google joined by
Martin part of the train and our special
guest Aaron who will be joining us later
in the video to help you modernize your
apps running on one of our serverless
compute platforms happy to be back quiz
now which app engine Legacy bundle
service are we migrating off of today
we've done datastore memcache and blob
store so far
you know I'm tired of showing people how
to migrate off them bundled Services
let's do the opposite and show users how
to keep using them instead
did you just say we're staying on app
engine Legacy services today what kind
of migration is this yeah in a little
bit of a plot twist our little friend
Porter will be taking you on a journey
as usual but this time rather than
migrating away from App engine bundled
Services we're going to show you how to
stay on those Legacy apis while
upgrading to the latest app engine
runtimes so you're still modernizing
your apps
okay I know what we're doing but I don't
know why can you explain to everyone out
there I thought the main reason for this
series was to get people off of app
engine dependencies like bundle services
and migrate to equivalent Cloud
Standalone services or to other
serverless platforms
you're right Martin but many users have
indicated it's more urgent for them to
upgrade language versions because older
ones aren't supported anymore also
migrating to a standalone service may
require more effort requiring a move to
Standalone Services before updating
language releases means two huge
challenges back to back now developers
can update language versions first and
then migrate to Standalone services on
their own timelines but what if I just
want to update to a newer language
release without migrating to Standalone
Services is that possible with
yes it is maybe I know why you want to
just update language releases but the
catch is that not all bundled services
are accessible from the latest runtimes
if your code doesn't use any of the
services listed in the not available
column then yes you can just update
language versions without migrating to
Standalone services
what if my app engine app does use one
of those not available
for bundle service is not available in
second gen runtimes you have to migrate
to a standalone cloud or a third-party
service take a look at this chart on
this page I'll drop a link down below to
see our migration recommendations
sounds good Wes so the first generation
app engine runtimes are python 2 Java 8
php5 and go 111 and older does upgrading
to newer versions affect these languages
in the same way
that's a really good question because
the answer is no each language runtime
enables access to the bundled services
in a different way for python you need
to switch web Frameworks add some
wrapper code and integrate with the app
engine SDK for Java you would add the
app engine bundled Services jar and
enable it in configuration and forgo and
PHP use the latest app engine SDK
okay so what are those changes needed
for python
while python code changes are needed the
most extensive changes switching from
web app 2 to another framework we
already did this in module one so let's
start there it's already been migrated
to flask so let's walk through the steps
needed from there to migrate it to
python3 but preserving datastore access
with the NDB bundled service join me on
the computer now to walk through those
steps
it's always good to start from a working
app in this case the module 1 sample
whether using your app from doing the
code lab or getting it from the repo
delete the lib folder if you have one
and run the PIP install command to
reinstall the third-party libraries
there python 2 developers know this is
how you bundle third-party libraries
with your app one benefit from upgrading
to Python 3 is that you no longer have
to self-bundle now run gcloud app deploy
to redeploy the module 1 app to the
cloud Point your browser to it and
verify it shows the most recent visits
now that we've confirmed it works let's
migrate it to python3 but continue to
use bundled services like app engine and
EB to talk to datastore it's much easier
to use third-party libraries with the
app engine Python 3 runtime you just
list them in requirements.txt in this
app we need the app engine SDK so add
app engine python standard to
requirements.txt and save next is
app.yaml at the top replace the runtime
directive with a supported Python 3
release today that would be 3.9 or 310
delete both the thread safe and API
version directives as neither are used
in Python 3. this app only has script
handlers so we can delete the entire
Handler section but if your app has
static file handlers leave them intact
and just remove the script handlers the
Python 3 runtime doesn't support
built-in third-party libraries so if you
had a library section in your app.yaml
delete it in Python 3 all third-party
libraries go into requirements.txt and
that's it a minute ago we added the app
engine SDK into requirements.txt and to
use the SDK at a a new app engine apis
directive set to true in app.yaml so it
now has just these two lines you see
here the SDK repo is linked down in the
video description below in case you're
interested what else we just mentioned
there's no more support for built-in
third-party libraries there's also no
more vendoring or copying of
non-built-in third-party libraries so
delete the lib folder if you have one
because all the third party stuff is now
in requirements that txt you don't need
app engine config.py either so delete
that too if you do need something
special say a private dependency and
you've got an artifact registry python
repository you can use a special extra
index URL option in requirements.txt to
bring in those dependencies there are a
couple of links down below to learn more
about private dependencies okay that's
it for config let's take a look at
main.py at the top import the whiskey
wrapper from the app engine SDK then use
it by wrapping the flask apps whiskey
object once it's wrapped you can use any
available bundled service like normal if
you haven't migrated from web app 2 yet
there's a link down below to the docs
page where you can see the module 0
python 2 web app 2 app lined up next to
this module 1B Python 3 flask app
upgrading to Python 3 is this
straightforward for the bundled services
that are available unless you're using
blob store deferred or mail apis we'll
talk more about them in a minute but
link below are the respective guides for
you to see how to use them in Python 3.
for this sample app we're done and only
need to deploy because all third-party
libraries are in requirements.txt and
you've deleted the lib folder and app
engine config.py there's no pip install
command so go straight to gcloud app
deploy to upload it to the cloud hit the
app from a browser or Coral to it and
when you see the most recent visits page
realize you now have a working Python 3
version of the sample app using the NDB
bundled service congrats okay wrapping
up app engine first gen had all these
bundled Services they were removed when
2nd gen launched in 2018 because we
wanted user apps to be more portable we
heard from customers who really wanted
them back so we brought back as many as
we could in 2021
there are more bundled service Python 3
sample apps in the migration repo for
those with an A and B folders like
modules 2 and 13 that means it uses a
standalone cloud service which can be
used by both python 2 and 3. but folders
with just a b without an a equivalent
like modules 7 and 12 that means they
use a bundle service now you know how to
use bundled services in Python 3. let's
get back to the vein program thanks for
the overview of the Python code changes
ah that wasn't too bad
yep and to repeat from earlier if your
app does use a bundled service that
isn't available in the Next Generation
runtimes migrate to a standalone or
third-party alternative some services
like blob store mail and deferred apis
need a bit more code tweaking but we'll
cover that in another module otherwise
the rest of the Legacy apis should work
just like they have also note that all
new features are going into all the
Standalone Services making these apis
available to our early adopters is
specifically to help with migration
efforts
that's great and I'm also glad our Java
go and PHP friends don't have to make
any code changes me too and I've invited
our friend Aaron to briefly cover what's
needed in Java to access the bundled
Services Aaron thanks Wes as a Java 8
developer you're familiar with app
engine and webxml serving as your main
configuration file you'll continue to
use that file when using the bundled
services in Java 11 or 17 runtimes but
you'll have to make two changes you'll
need to add the app engine apis jar as a
dependency and add a line of config that
enables the use of Legacy bundled
services and that's really it when you
eventually migrate away from the bundled
services in your Java 11 or 17 app you
can use app.yaml for config instead
we've also got links below to the
documentation on accessing the bundled
services on all the next gen runtimes
cool thanks Aaron for joining Wes and me
today to help our Java developers now
west the team removed access to all
these bundle Services when the second
generation of app engine launched why
did they do that well the main reason
was that many folks felt that writing
against proprietary apis was too
restricted for them users wanted their
apps to be more portable plus many of
app engine's bundle Services had matured
to become their own Standalone products
anyway so the decision was made to
launch the second generation run temps
without these bundled services so that
apps would be more portable
ah that makes sense especially since
Google wants to have the most open Cloud
out there
so why are we then adding access to
these bundle Services back into app
engine another good question well guess
what we listen to user feedback and many
of them told us that some of those
features are what brought them to app
engine to begin with so that's why the
team tried to bring back as many as were
feasible cool thanks for explaining it's
great that developers can now update to
a more modern language release without
having first to migrate off of the
bundle Services that's right Martin
users can now upgrade language versions
and then migrate to the Standalone
Services when they're ready giving them
much more flexibility in modernizing
their apps
ah you mean they can then take advantage
of those serverless migration Station
videos we've already done yep like
moving from App engine datastore to
cloud data store see modules two and
three push tasks the cloud tasks see
module 789 memcache to Cloud memory
store C modules 12 and 13 blobster to
cloud storage in modules 15 and 16 and
so on if you're considering
containerizing your app engine apps for
cloud run see modules four and five for
doing so with and without Docker and for
migrating small app engine apps to Cloud
functions see module 11. good I'm glad
we can make the bundle services
available to help with migration efforts
last question what about ruby and
node.js are they also app engine
runtimes ah yes that's right since
they're the newest languages supported
we can't open a wormhole to the Past
because they never had first generation
runtimes with bundled Services the good
news is they don't have any migration to
perform because they're already using
the latest and greatest our early
adopters need more help and that's what
we're here for
and we look forward to having you join
us for those migrations this is Wes on
behalf of Martin Aaron and Porter we
hope to see you at another migration
station or on another serverless
Expedition soon happy travels
[Music]